it's uh I think more and more women have
been told that in order for them to get
credit they have to be super career
driven they have to make loads of money
they have to focus on achievement and so
when women pursue that they tend to be
in their masculine energy a lot and
being a stay-at-home wife or raising a
family it doesn't it's not seen as as
valuable
but I would argue insane to some point I
agree with you but argue and say like if
women are
a single parents
um and how to raise their children by
themselves they're looked upon as
masculine as well but they've been at
home raising the family and to some for
often of their own or not or their own
like the the father of their children is
not there but they still have to raise
the children but they are willing to be
that housewife Etc
um but they looked upon us being
masculine because they're saying well
you're a single parent and you're a
single parent for a reason so I feel
sometimes as a female regardless what
role we play is sometimes hard to kind
of say all right which way do we go do
we go down a feminine route or do we
have to go down sometimes
though like femininity and masculinity
it's all contextual and it's not black
and white so for me personally in
business I show up as pretty masculine
like you know the very typical boss
business babe whatever and then in my
relationship I'm the opposite and that's
because I had to unlearn a lot of the
social program coming that told me that
my worth came from Curious success and I
had to relearn like what men really want
in a relationship which is they want a
woman to make them feel appreciated
supported they want a woman to like
bring out his masculine even more and
play the feminine role they really
looked down on being the mother now if
you just wanted to go home and you work
maybe part-time if you can't afford to
do it and then everyone just looked down
on you on that that's a bad thing to do
you've done that for a man I find that's
yeah my friend Ali I was telling you
guys before the show she went viral for
just saying yeah my um my husband's my
boss I work for him yeah he makes the
decision yeah yeah I was I was the one
behind the camera yeah yeah that was
that was not my account yeah that's
crazy like all the all the comments were
basically saying how could you trust him
like well he could just leave you high
and drive but it's like everything you
do has risk like there's risk in being a
single parent there's ever like you can
get married you could get divorced like
life is risk I think what we're talking
about here with what you said Levine and
what you said Hannah is about emotional
intelligence so it's being able to
switch on and switch off and apply
yourself effectively in different
situations and scenarios whether it's
masculine energy or feminine yeah yeah
and just understanding the two and then
when to play which role accordingly yeah
sometimes I feel men struggle with that
as well
like
you're absolutely right men do want to
feel like they are the man and they want
to feel wanted and they want to feel
like their purpose in the in
relationship but sometimes there are
some men if they've never been shown
that as a young person or a child they
won't know how to do that as an adult
and sometimes as a woman we can be
patients and like I can show you that
but if they're not willing to receive
that love from it's very hard
relationships are just a thing that a
not a lot of people taught and because
people don't do the self-development
work on themselves they expect something
else somebody else outside of them to
validate who they are and what they do
whereas they don't have that internal
self-belief that internal validation
which is which is important yeah in
saying that as well I feel like based on
the solely of personal experience right
um as a young man I used to wear glasses
in it so I threw out my whole secondary
school year I had glasses on so I didn't
really have the confidence to be like to
approach women in that sort of way and
format because and then the moment I
turned 19 got laser eye surgery lost my
glasses hit the gym I mean did all these
things I never used to do and then and
realized I was like yo I'm kind of I'm
kind of a spice right now I'm kind of
good just saying I never went to UNI and
then I I lost my virginity when I was at
Uni and then that just opened up a whole
new doors of experience that I didn't
experience before so
um when it comes to the younger men
coming up nowadays I feel like yeah they
have no because they have no Guidance Do
you know what I mean they have no one to
say well how how are they supposed to be
taught about women if like I want to say
half of people raised by single mothers
or like a word that was that I was gonna
get to that point I am raised by a
single mother when it came to asking my
dad about for stuff like hey that you
know I mean how does it do to you know
do certain sexual activities with a
woman do you know he wasn't around I
don't know I'll say I was just no
problem I said it on my channel
yeah yeah I was thinking um sorry uh no
go on women have been been encouraged to
go off and be independent on their own
and if their meaning was to you know
find a husband have children look after
children and their men were to get a job
find a wife and then provide for them
and the women have gone off the men have
nothing now to look what there's there's
no wives around so they're just
completely what percent of women would
you say want to be wives and what
percent of women would you say are wives
I want to hear from the men
and your experience
carry on the conversation that's you
right there
I'm choosing to go last I bet a lot
lie to themselves so I bet it's higher
than they think so I'm going to say
about 80 want to be wives yeah
very they say 30 are wives yeah okay
yeah I think I would I would agree a lot
with that I think a lot of women want to
be wives but they don't have the
substance or the skills to actually
um support the lifestyle of the person
that they would ideally like to be with
so then they end up with somebody that
is not fully compatible with and they go
on my relationship's all right it will
it will last and you know we have our
ups and downs and they have those sorts
of tumultuous relationships that don't
really work out long term but most women
don't have the the skill sets to be
wives to the men that they aspire to be
with and what skills would you say those
are
patience communication I think
communication is one of the most the
most powerful ones because a lot of
women have
in my experience at least have a lot of
self-doubt and they don't they don't
know how to be supportive to somebody
else they don't know how to communicate
powerfully with somebody else in a ways
that
helps their relationship to grow helps
their relationship to flourish and helps
their relationship to be really
effective
do you think women have self-doubt
because I find them to be more
narcissistic than ever yeah is it is it
a fake narcissistic though because it's
like an external narcissism but an
internal I don't feel good about this I
don't feel I'm worth it no I feel like
I'll just like even at carnival I was
asking like rate yourself one to ten and
they would say ten I'm like
and then I'd ask I'd say well aren't you
perfect doesn't that mean you're perfect
she's like well I'm not perfect but I am
and then they'd say special but isn't it
kind of narcissistic to think you're
special yeah like she's like everyone
thinks they're special like it's been
proven in Psychology that everyone as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible